[Music]
ryan is in columbus ohio hi ryan welcome
to the dave ramsey show
hi david john thanks for taking my call
sure what's up
um so my wife and i just paid off our
house last october so we're in baby step
seven and we're trying to figure out
yeah
we're trying to figure out what to do
with the extra money we're having from
not having a mortgage payment
way to go such problems
yeah so my wife's the dentist and she's
currently buying into the practice that
she works at
we're actually able to do this without
taking out a loan by her paying her a
partner each month
for equity in the practice and then
their plan was to do this for four
years and then at the end of the fourth
year she would purchase the rest of the
practice from him
so we're currently in the last year of
that plan
and we're planning on getting a business
loan to pay off the rest of the practice
you know after this year so my question
is
with that um with that business loan
coming up in the next year
and we have all this extra money from
not having a house payment anymore
should we save up that money and take
out a smaller loan
yep or should we more know here to save
for retirement or no loan
yeah can you how much is the loan how
much is the uh
buyout at the end of the end of the year
it's about 480 000 that you're gonna
need
more than if she's already paid in
yes whoo
so it's a serious practice or you're
seriously overpaying
um um okay anyway i i want you to go
relook those numbers and just make sure
that you're not overpaying
for this uh dentists yeah have a
reputation for overpaying
yeah we have a uh we have a accountant
that works in uh buying out dental
practices
he looked at the numbers and he said for
our area
for the size of the practice this was a
good price
he actually said we're getting a deal so
okay all right it must be mammoth
okay um okay so what's your household
income
um combined right now with her paying
her partner
is about two hundred thousand dollars
okay but then after
sh after she owns the entire practice
she says
we'll probably be uh 350 000
conservatively okay
so uh yeah what i would like you to do
is to save as much as you can possibly
save
almost like you're on baby step two
again
real intensity because i really don't
want you to have this loan but it sounds
like you're going to
but let's make it as small as you can
possibly make it and then let's pay it
off as fast as you possibly can
um okay we've done a lot of work over
the years with a lot of dentists
in entre leadership and also just in
financial coaching
and um the uh
the amount of debt around being a
dentist is
it's it's mind-blowing in general
and in that in the community that your
wife works
walks in every day uh a million dollars
or a half million dollars in debt for
the rest of your life
is not unusual it's standard
and you can get sucked into that
paradigm and i'm gonna challenge you not
to
i'm gonna challenge you to get this paid
off like it was a credit card
like you were ashamed of this debt you
follow me
yep don't normalize it and keep it like
it's a dadgum pet
so limit the size of it this year by
saving everything you get your hands on
and then get into um attack mode
and finish and take out as a small loan
as you can then take that loan out
and it sounds to me like you can take
that loan out in uh 12 to 18 months from
the time you
it's going to be a very short period of
time if you guys won't go back and act
like now i'm a rich dentist or something
i i did some research back in grad
school on the mental health of doctors
and physicians and nurses
and one of the worst subgroups was
dentists and i have to
wonder high rate of shock hi we'll have
to wonder if it's
this crushing debt that you just carry
around and carry around that's normed in
that community more so than some of
these other
communities yeah the um
borrowed future podcast that we did we
interviewed a dentist that had over a
million dollars in debt
student loans yeah and the guy was just
crying yeah
he was just crying because you can't you
can't clean your teeth you can't clean
your way out of that right
yeah well you can but it's just i mean
but it takes one
you gotta have a you gotta have a
certain level of and you gotta
you gotta have some specialization in
the thing or you gotta have some volume
or something
to get the income up but it sounds like
she's gonna be making
uh out of the 350 uh i'm i don't know
but i mean it sounds like she's gonna be
making
chunk of money quarter million dollars a
year her part so um
yeah let's use that let's use everything
we can to to limit this
and then when you don't have any
payments in the world and you're making
350.
now you're in the agreement to do all
kinds of things right and it does change
the way you operate a business it
changes the way you
view going to work it changes when you
own a practice or you own a business
when you get the debt off of you it the
borrower is slave the lender it changes
the way you
stand the way you walk the way you carry
yourself